[Music]  for the main course remember and olive  oil to a hot pan remove the fat from the  steaks roll out thin and seasoned fry  quickly on both sides then set aside  into the same pan add chopped shallots  and season add sliced mushrooms another  butter and crush garlic  then add a splash of Worcester sauce and  Dijon mustard  pour a dash of brandy and flambe  once the alcohol is burnt off swirl the  juices add the cream and stir in chopped  parsley return the steaks and cook saute  potatoes heat oil slice the Powerball  potatoes in half and place cut side down  season add crushed garlic and rosemary  plate up and spoon the sauce over the  steaks State Diane with soda potatoes  and peas done  [Music]